well good afternoon and it's a great
pleasure to be here thank you very much
for inviting me again and thank you for
the introduction reference the
introductory reference to Cal Grant
indeed when I came to innsbruck he was
not there anymore he was just retired
but his spirit was every everywhere and
he used to come to give lectures so in
thank you for the reference to the
social gospel indeed those were the days
when I study theology 69 73 when the
interlink you know Jurgen Moltmann
which was the great kind of theologian
with whom Miroslav studied and met the
catholic political theologian and
liberation theology was worse than
emerging latin america and how much
basically when i studied the social
gospel the similarities of course are
very very great now again time is of the
essence here i don't have that much time
to actually waste time on this nice
remarks i should go directly to the
topic namely faith as shapers of
globalization and of course we can only
take this seriously even if we have a
very expansive conception of both of a
globalization of faith you have a very
narrow degrees of globalization of
course it is irrelevant the relationship
and especially we also reviews faith and
I guess that's the interesting question
why faith and not religion perhaps
because faith is a much more expansive
concept that incorporates broadly
culture and even they're kind of
unthought in some style or sense of
those things we take so much for granted
that we do not even question them they
are simply unthinkable not to think
through them they think through us
nothing we think in them and in this
respect this is the kind of cultures the
question a Presbyterian eighth is
precisely this the anecdote about
Northern Ireland crossing from a
Catholic to a Protestant hands up
where are you Protestant Catholic no I
mean ethics but which one the Protestant
or Catholic ultimately yes there
thing as a secular person there is no
secular person in the abstract every
secular is a post-christian secular most
Catholic a post-carbon is a post so but
let's let's make him first with the
expansive conception of globalization I
don't know which kind of working
definition you are using in this course
and according to this definition when
does globalization begin I'm going to
give you a very expansive definition and
I'm going to say there are three phases
of globalization the first phase is the
original process of emigration of Homo
sapiens Out of Africa and the Homo
sapiens settles the entire globe
he's a facing widget with a material
base for globalization of a single
humanity settling the entire globe but
no reflexive consciousness whatsoever
and only through DNA and other
technology we can reconstruct this
process today we know it happened so
this was the original face of
globalization the second phase is
consciousness without material base and
it takes place in the axial revolution
when simultaneously you may have heard
of the theory of color Jasper's axiality
simultaneously and this is not that
relevant but this interesting it around
the same time two or three centuries
you have simultaneously a breakthrough
in the consciousness of humanity have
been able to somehow encounter or
discover transcendence the possibility
of transcends one place once time one
society and to think in universal terms
and so we have that people Confucius
Buddha Socrates Plato the Old Testament
prophet Jeremiah Isaiah Zoroaster all of
these are contemporaries and all of
those are a founders of our
civilizations and those are what we call
faiths world religion civilizations it's
very important of course not all of them
are religious transcendence let the
Plato's conception of the allegory of
the caves the ideas if you have a very
sponsored definition of religion is the
sacred need
hmmm sense the way Robert Bellah uses
the use of course platonic philosophy is
a form of religion it is with the sacred
and indeed it also offered a form of
salvation to those who actually follow
the ideas and this kind of philosophy
Confucius you could set the towel there
are elements of religion but clearly is
not a religion in the sense in which we
think of religion even Buddhism is not a
stick person obviously the most clear
concept a theistic transcendence is with
with a monotheistic creator god of the
Old Testament but the point is that here
you have Confucius did not develop an
ethic for Chinese it was an ethic for
humans Socrates did not develop an ethic
for Greeks it wasn't a thing for humans
for them there was no question the laws
were universal normal principles and the
God of Israel is the God of all people
and the same thing you could say about
Buddha so this moment when people
conceptualize anticipate well before it
is materially possible the possibility
of one single global humanity sharing a
view with the same time and space the
same consciousness the same norms this
is really the anticipatory phase of
globalization that only becomes then
materially possible realized in our age
our age of globalization but it may not
have been possible without the others
and now here you enter into we know that
in terms of if the process of expansion
of a populations with the first
migrations was material the second one
already the expansion of Christianity
beyond the Middle East of Buddhism
beyond India of all of those spreads of
these faiths that become transnational
trans political trans empires
again there are still very much embedded
in material
imperial civilizations but they all of
them have the possibility of transcends
the Pope the Bishop of Rome always
claimed to speak all be at orbit to the
city and to the globe of course this was
never a reality until the second half of
the 20th century but now it has become a
reality and this is what every world
religion can do today at the same one
claiming
we are these unique very particular
istic faith at the same time claiming we
are the best faithful of humanity and
all of them do that the interesting
dynamic going on today is the way in
which each of the faiths claims that the
same to be unique and different and they
want to preserve this unique difference
visibly the others at the same time
claiming somehow that they are a
universal response form of humanity and
this is where the very interesting
dynamics of globalization and faiths
then enters how this globalization this
process of this consciousness we all
share the same space in the same time
effects then these faiths that were
until now territorially the limited to
particular and demographically the
limited to particular areas of in
particular groups of the population and
the process whereby today all of them
can become dt8 realized and become sort
of global faith at large you may be
familiar with the the title of Arjun
Appadurai modernity at large
well global religions at large that's
what each religion is becoming today and
in I would argue we are in a moment of
global denominationalism where a process
of mutual recognition of all the faith's
both accepting the differences between
the faith and yet trying to claim the
share commonality of the faces these a
lot of conflict is placing this process
of recognition is not necessarily only
interfaith religious dialogue sometimes
it is a very nasty conflict that this
recognition takes place so this is one
very aspect of the dynamic of
globalization and faiths which are
interlinked today
there of course has to do with the
question of how each of these faiths
then itself shapes the particular form
of modernity if you'll follow my essay
the claim is that the secular begins
first as a Christian theological
category is part of a Christian
theological conception of the cosmos of
the universe of reality and precisely
because of that the analytical
transformation
of Christianity can be understood as a
process of secularization is a very
unique Christian dynamic that could not
be reproduced anywhere in the world what
is wrong with a theory of secularization
is it was developed by the Enlightenment
was the notion that this price of
Christian secularization is part of a
global universal process of transition
from religion to non religion that was
primitive religion at the time and then
there will be no religion after so these
frameworks are from religion so it it
generalizes one process of if you with D
confessional izing Christianity and
creating a kind of Christian culture
without churches which is what very much
the preserve of of Western modernization
were said to be and how then this
however this particular Western process
which is uniquely Kristin and one has an
increase in I'm I would even say Western
Christian there is no concept of the
secular in Eastern Christianity in
Byzantium it's only a Western Christian
concept and because of that only where
you have this concert you can actually
have a dynamic of secularization and
what it is dynamic the dynamic is to
eliminate to solve the dualism between
the religious and the secular the
religious which is represented in the
monasteries and the second in the world
and the whole process has always two
logics one to get rid of the walls by
bringing the religion into the sacrum
transforming the sacral according to
Christian principles to try to transform
reality according to Christian
principles this is one of the dynamics
of secularization this what Luther did
let's all be monks in the world let's
not be monks in the monastery let's all
be monks in the war what is the
Protestant model of precisely eliminate
not so much
eliminating or maintaining the
boundaries and keeping religion
separated but really almost eliminating
the boundaries or diffusing the
boundaries by making the religious
secular in the secular non-religious so
they again you can be a secular
Presbyterian it is a peer what it's a
very modest Presbyterian in this mixture
and this is why for Europeans is so
difficult to understand what
America is because indeed it is so
secular they didn't count as religious
anymore as most Europeans tend to tend
to say about American religion but there
is another model which is the dynamic
weighting rid of the priests of getting
rid of clerical ecclesiastical
institutions the dynamic of laicism and
to build to create secular structures
which are not anymore under the control
of religious authority it is these two
dynamics eliminate the separation and
but then the secular is not what remains
that was always there after you get rid
of the superstructure which is religion
we must get rid of this notion that the
secular is really the authentic human
which is there and you only have to get
rid of this thing that someone was added
to us religion which is not really
natural was the supernatural thing added
and once you get rid of it the natural
human secular image no the secular is a
construction the construction and is of
course the great thesis of of Charles
Taylor and it shows how much our
Christian our secular Western secular is
how Christian it is how much it is
permeated by notions of love agape the
whole notion of solidarity and we could
go on through different types of
cultural conceptions into the home as
they are linked to Christian norms
values but of course we know that this
particular dynamic which for whatever
reasons develops out of the West is
linked to the process of global colonial
expansion of European powers and then
becomes globalized but then becomes
globalizing the way that enters in
dynamic encounters with other
civilizations other phase which have a
different way of establishing these
boundaries between transcendent and in
man and sacred profane religious secular
and and sometimes we take these parallel
terms this binary imminent transcendence
profane sacred secular religious as if
they will be synonymous they are not
they correspond to different ways of
classifying those things it is not clear
what is the broader concept and how they
feel within one another
there's why many of our problems dealing
with these concepts is the relation
precisely between what is sacred and
profane is very clear that prior to the
axial ages the sacred and profane both
were imminent then emerges transcendence
but transcended doesn't need to be
religious and we have the secular today
but the secular is not profane the
secular can be very sacred sacred
nationhood sacred citizenship sacred
science so it is simply that the
categories we have do not help us to try
to conceptualize all these things and of
course it is because of our secularists
narrow conceptions that sometimes we
have no way of dealing with those issues
but then the question is okay and of
course one could argue even they attempt
to argue that even Christian
developments were in early separate
least and development we know that it is
not true that the very Christian
developments cannot be understood
without the links with Judaism with
Islam and the DS themselves are linked
to so all these civilizations never were
clearly territorially separated
boundaries that were always encounters
are always hybrids and none of them can
be understood in its own terms and again
fade when we talk of faith how do we
separate the Christian the religious
Christian from the secular Christian
there are debates in Europe today
whether turkey should belong to Europe
or not it's precisely about that the
difficult this would be fine in Europe
obviously you cannot define it in
religious terms as Christian Europe
because half of Europe NZ but I'm not
Christian you cannot define the purely
as secular because because then you have
a lot of Christians still in Europe
which are not secular and the poor about
turkeys that precise is neither
Christian nor secular but is Muslim and
it needs all the criteria of democracy
the rules which the European Union has
basically established for entering the
Union but then the whole issue of what
is this culture what are we who are we
Europeans visibly the rest of the world
well we have this human rights but human
rights are universal rights now European
right so the whole issue of how do we
define ourselves these are the other
cultures what
this faith European faith what is the
system of European faith the
distinguished Europeans from others in
which is what is the the kind of
criteria to let people in or keep them
out those are very kind of diff
difficult issues and we are in the
process today in the world in which all
these civilizations are coming to terms
and are encountering one another
Darwin was mentioned obviously we are at
the kind of paradoxical moment in which
we humans as a species has come to
recognize our single humanity our
history view is is one process of
evolution but of course the theory was
one of random evolution which works
until culture enters in we know that
one's history one culture takes over is
not so random anymore there is a
different process of human evolution
which is cultural evolution which is
very much linked to religion and the
interesting question is that we are in
the moment now in which both we can for
the first time if you wish right a
collective autobiography of how we got
here how we all have become one single
global humanity with very diverse
precisely multiple humanity or multiple
types of being human in the same time
we're at the moment in which we could
simply sub destroy ourselves or try to
precisely end evolution random evolution
and try to direct it through scientific
management or simply you know how to
destroy ourselves the environment in
which we live those are the kind of
questions as globalization raises also
it's not only a question about obviously
economic development but it is this
awareness that the relation moment when
we have become really one single global
humanity sharing world history we are
now somehow responsible for the next
phase of globalization and we'll have to
somehow all come together to decide how
do we do it and I think that the model
of economic cosmopolitan secularism
between there is new that
rest of the world's going to become like
us it's not viable anymore and that we
had to let all faiths if you way of
humanity come in in together come to
them come to terms with our past how we
got here where we are now and how we are
going to construct our future together